the first thing I'll always say is be
yourself and I know that sounds so so
simple but it's something that loads
people fail to do I failed to do in a
state agency I worked in Henley which is
like quite a well to do areas a lot of
Posh people there and I'm so far from
that but my boss was like right when
people come in you need to be like yes
sir Madam and it just it didn't work
like that's not who I am that's not how
I speak that people see right through it
so you've got to be yourself and it was
only when I started showing up as myself
that I made some really good connections
and relationships with clients when you
are yourself those relationships that
you're going to build they're authentic
they're going to work with you because
they're you
foreign